hello everyone i am will dampier
i am an assistant professor at the
department of microbiology and
immunology
at the drexel university college of
medicine in
philadelphia pa and today i'd like
to first thank the organizers for this
opportunity
to present my research here
i'd like to tell everybody about this
these projects that i do using deep
learning
and how to do
text and image processing techniques to
look at sequence analysis
and i want to do this in the context of
hiv infection
which currently affects roughly 36
million people across the world
now hiv infection is
characterized by two main biomarkers the
viral load or how much virus is
circulating within the patient
and the white blood cell count or the
cd4
positive cells now during the initial
infection the patient the viral load
will
rapidly increase and the cd4 count
will decrease because those are the
cells that hiv is actually infecting and
destroying
however their immune system will often
recover over the course of a few weeks
and they may not even realize that
they've been infected
however over the course of months to
years
they'll enter the sphere period of
clinical latency in which the virus
slowly depletes
the white blood cell population and
increases
its own this is often when they come to
the doctor
and uh the introduction of
antiretroviral therapy
will within weeks to months reduce this
viral load back down to near
undetectable levels
and allow the white blood cell count to
recover
and as long as they stay on their
medication this can persist
for years however if they ever interrupt
their medication
the virus will rapidly rebound and
that's because during the initial weeks
of the early infection the virus seeded
anatomical reservoirs like the brain and
the gi tract
as well as circulating cells like
macrophages and memory t cells
now these clinical events correspond to
genetic events within the virus as well
so when a patient
is initially infected they're often
challenged with
a wide collection of genetically related
viruses
however through selection pressure often
is only a single virus that produces
the infection within the individual
during the time in which they're
infected but don't know it
the virus will rapidly replicate however
the error-prone process
of its reverse transcriptase causes
a genetic diversity to emerge within
this population
that expands over the course of years
now once they're on therapy the amount
of circulating virus can
go down to undetectable levels and even
if with our most sensitive methods we
often only see a
single circulating variant within the
population
however we know that in these anatomical
and cellular reservoirs
there's a collection of latent virus
there's the entire history
that this patient has been exposed to
now there are many parts of hiv that we
can explore
but today i want to just talk about
one viral protein called tat now
here i've shown the viral diversity of a
large
collection of publicly available
sequences
across the entire genome and we can see
that it is quite diverse across the
entire genome
the hiv tat protein is encoded in two
exons across the virus in moderately
diverse areas when transcribed these two
exons
create a protein with roughly six
functional domains
that goes and does many activities of
the virus
its namesake the transactivator of
transcription
in this process hiv transcription
is often very leaky and not very
efficient
however when the tat is able to bind to
the tar
rna a very immature part one of the
first parts of viral transcripts
it stabilizes its complex with ptfe
allowing for longer transcripts to be
created
which in turn creates more tat which in
turn
creates more transcription creating a
positive feedback loop
which can allow this virus to escape
latency
cat has also been implicated in numerous
issues
in the neurocognitive implications
of hiv now the virus itself cannot cross
the blood-brain barrier
however it can infect macrophages as
they're in the bloodstream
which can then cross the blood-brain
barrier
these infected macrophages will produce
numerous viral
proteins that are excreted into this
privileged space
the one of which is tat which has
neurological uh or neurotropic
uh problems
so in this context i want to talk about
how
techniques developed for neural networks
and other contexts
can be used to explore hiv genetic
variation in tap
i want to talk about how techniques for
sentiment analysis which are used
to tell whether you like a movie or not
from a tweet
can be used for
predicting gene functions i want to talk
about how
techniques that can distinguish between
two faces
are able to be used and repurposed to
find
the human proteins that interact with
viral proteins
and then i want to talk about how
generative map networks or networks
in which they're trained to devise
new things how they can be used to
explore
different variants
so i'm going to start with sentiment
analysis
now in the interest of time i'm going to
go through this a little quickly
but when we process
sequences through neural networks
we first break them into a series of
tokens much like you might break a
sentence into a series of words
these are passed through what we call an
embedding layer
which assigns a vector for each
individual token
and these vectors represent the
contextual meaning
of the words so in a language context
the phrase i really like the movie and i
really dislike the movie
those two words have distinctly
different usages
that's what's captured by an embedding
in the sequence context
the three letter mcg is often an
eukaryotic degradation signal that's
found at the end of proteins
where the three letters dpf correspond
to an ap2 binding site which is often in
the middle of the protein
we have convolutional layers
these are layers that
move o move across a sequence
to find short patterns or phrases
we might think of these in the sequence
context as sequence
logos these are
weights of amino acids or nucleotides
that are responsible for a binding
we have recurrent networks these
networks
account for the order in which patterns
appear
by processing a sequence while
maintaining an
internal state that is updated as the
sequence is processed
so the two sentences really you liked it
and you really liked it while they both
contain the same
four words have distinctly opposite
meanings
recurrent network will be able to
capture that
and then in a sequence context we might
think of this as how complex 3d
structure
is important to understand whether
motifs will be on the inside or the
outside of a protein
now these two items together are often
blocked
and repeated to allow
one to extract more complex
patterns of patterns of patterns
and then those features are fed into a
densely connected network
and the purpose of these is to convert
the features
found previously into the actual
task specific predictions so this
is what allows a language model to
distinguish between sentences with
positive or negative sentiment
or in our context predicting
protein function from the sequences
now neural network can actually be
implemented with
minimal coding nowadays so using the pi
torch
neural network architecture we can
define the structure of a network
create the early embedding layers
create these recurrent blocks
produce this prediction structure
and then describe how data should flow
between each one of these blocks
in only about a hundred lines of code
now if we want to train a neural network
that can map
amino acid sequence to gene function we
need a database that has
that type of mapping and nicely the gene
ontology
database is a structured
vocabulary of gene functions
that are annotated across the unipro
database
which is a database of sequences
across many organisms so after filtering
for go terms that are rare and may not
be
easy have many observations we find that
there are roughly
500 000 sequences in the database
that contain these roughly 7 000 go
terms
after splitting them in order to have
both a training and validation cohort
we're still left with about 400 000
observations
now neural networks are trained by
structuring these mathematical graphs
passing data through and comparing
the output to the true
the true response variable and then
any differences are
updated in the weights through back
propagation
and gradient descent and these
sequences are passed through the network
over and over and over again
allowing it to extract as much data as
possible
as much knowledge as possible
so here i'm showing how the training
data
converges in the independent set of
validation data
reflects that it is able to distinguish
on proteins it has not seen before
now cross-entropy loss is a little bit
difficult to reason
about we often think about things as
the trade-off between sensitivity and
specificity in the class bar
called the area under the receiver
operator curve
now this number would be 1.0 if it was
perfect
and one-half if it was just randomly
guessing
uh and we can see that it is quite
accurate now not all go terms
are we able to predict as accurately
there are some that are more difficult
than others
these tend to be the rarer ones
and this work that i'm sort of
discussing here is built upon
some work on the deep go model first
published in 2018.
so just to go through how to read these
figures uh first
each row corresponds to a known
function of cat one of the 72 they're in
the gene ontology database
each column corresponds
to a specific pac patient
cat sequence uh they're about 6 000 of
them so we can't see each individual one
and then the color corresponds to how
likely the network believes that this
uh function should be associated with
the protein
now up here is an interesting collection
of subcellular localization
obviously had to take off the labels
because they won't fit with 72 of them
there
but this actually led to one of our
students going off and writing a
review to explore how
and the different mechanisms in which
cat could be excreted
from the cell but as we look back here
we see that there's kind of a lot of
functions that seem to be rare
and there's a lot of functions that seem
to be missing
right that these are functions that we
know tat does
but our network does not seem to be able
to predict them very well
and here we have to think a little bit
towards our biological common sense
earlier i put this figure up
and uh to sort of describe how tat
works we see that most of its functions
come from its binding ability so if
we're looking for motifs
they're associated with functions the
tat does
those motifs are not on tat
itself they're on the sequences
or excuse me they're on the proteins the
tad is binding to
and influencing uh their activity
so we need a different neural network to
explore
cat's functions in these ways
so now i want to talk about how we can
repurpose techniques from facial
recognition
to look at how hiv proteins interact
with human ones
so if you haven't seen this episode of
csi
you've probably seen some other
procedural in which
they take a person and they take their
face
and they measure the points on their
face they try to map the two
together this is called key point
matching
and in it either a person or an
algorithm
assigns one of these these points to the
to the figure or to the uh picture of
the face
and um then
measure the distance between two of the
points
and if we have a collection of people
those
numbers will sort of fall on a graph
and if we measure a new face and it's
somebody that's in the database
their number should be similar to one
that's already there
however due to the inherent limitations
of the structures of our face
as we add more and more
faces to this database it will
inherently become
more and more populated and have more
and more
false positives so in order to address
this
the facial recognition community came up
with a technique called
triplet loss now in triplet loss you
start with
two images of the same person
here two of will ferrell and one of an
unrelated person this is chad smith from
the red hot chili peppers
then we pass these through a neural
network that is designed
to convert these images into just
vectors of numbers
into just 128 number vector
then we adjust the neural network
so that the distances between the
vectors
that come from the faces of the same
person are closer
together and the distance between the
vectors of the unrelated person is
increased then as we feed
more and more faces through this
algorithm it will naturally
form clusters
and if we have an image for a person
that's in the database it will be
inside the cluster and if we have an
image for a person that has not been in
the database
they'll actually be distant from all
clusters
and neural networks trained with this
method are perfectly capable of
distinguishing between
will ferrell and chat smith when they
dress up as each other
now protein protein interaction
prediction can be framed as a triplet
loss problem
here in facial recognition we have two
pictures of person a
an unrelated person we can also
take in protein protein interactions to
part
protein binding partners and unrelated
protein
and using a database of about seven
thousand
human binding triplets like this
and the neural network that was already
constructed
in order to convert proteins into
vectors
we're able to train a neural network
that could predict
which two proteins interact with each
other
and find a very high degree of accuracy
so i took the hiv proteins and we have a
collection of
known uh interactions that's maintained
by the ncbi
that map known hiv and human protein
protein interactions
so i i took these proteins and i threw
them through the network
and i was kind of unimpressed with the
results
you see here that my accuracy
my area under the curve is you know
0.5.6.7
but this is because this neural network
has never seen
an hiv protein it's only ever seen human
proteins
and so it doesn't know what type of
proteins
these hiv ones will react so we can use
a process called
transfer learning in which we take the
network that was already trained
and provide it with a subset of new data
and allow it to continue its learning
and when we do this we find that we get
a drastic increase a recovery of our
ability to predict
hiv human protein interactions
so here this is a similar graph except
now
each row corresponds to a human protein
that tat interacts with uh but there are
about a thousand of them so we can't
show them all
again there's
a collection of these proteins here
that we're terming as constitutive
binders
that from all hiv patients
their tasks will always bind to these
genes
and we use gene ontology enrichment to
look at the functions of these genes
we find that they're primarily involved
in interfering with the immune system
if there's one thing the cat needs to do
for hiv
it's help it evade the immune system
and then down here we have a collection
of proteins
that were terming conditional binders so
not all
patients habitat that will bind to these
human proteins
now there are many interesting things uh
in these collections of proteins
but the one i'm going to talk about is
its effect on calcium dysregulation
so is able cat is able to bind
to a large number of proteins that are
involved
in ion homeostasis in particular
calcium dysregulation one particular one
that we're interested in our lab
is called grin1 which is the ncbi
gene id for the nmdma receptor
a common receptor found on neurons
uh we've actually developed a
r01 that's been looking at
how hiv tat
may be interfering with
the activity of the nmdma receptor
and dysregulating calcium causing
some of the neurological complications
of hiv
so lastly i want to talk about how we
can leverage generative networks
in order to do a unique variant
prediction
of hiv and i started this talk
thinking or describing that there are
roughly 36 million people
in the world living with hiv however
we've sequenced
barely a hundred thousand of them across
all of science but
the rest of this genetic variation is
not random
right there are things we know about hiv
sequence and can explain
it has some phylogeny relationships uh
there's difference between subtypes
across the world
and we know how art interferes with that
there are things we know but can't quite
explain
like how the structure to function
relationships are important
in uh in the sequence of the proteins
and how immune pressure may influence
that
and then there are things we don't know
and can't explain
so i want to talk about a different type
of neural network
one that can actually imagine new
things so the faces you're looking at
here
don't exist uh there are no people with
these faces they were
imagined by a computer from
a collection of random numbers
you can actually go to this person does
not
exist.com and get an infinite stream
of these faces
now not all excuse me not all of the
faces are perfect
uh this one here on the left you can see
that it doesn't understand
level of symmetry across faces
here you can see that it's particularly
poor at replicating jewelry
and sometimes it just puts people in
weird kaleidoscope worlds
in which they live with a whole bunch of
feet around them
so these images were generated
using a model called a generative
adversarial
neural network and these networks
are designed to take in random noise
and convert that into a random
object in another space so we'll take a
random set of numbers
and generate a random face that
corresponds
to those numbers and sometimes that face
has a weird person behind it
now it showed in the original papers
that this works for more than just faces
you could give it
birds or planes or bikes
or bedrooms or boats
you'll be able to create convincingly
real yet fake images of all of them
and then some work in 2017
showed that this would also be possible
to do with dna
so we took this and generated our
created our own gan
to look at hiv tax sequences
so these types of models we take noise
or literal random numbers uh
and we pass them into a black box that's
designed
through convolutional neural networks to
turn
those numbers into random letters
a's t's g's and c's
and then we combine that with a
collection of
true cat sequences and we have a whole
bunch of these
and then we create another convolutional
neural network
that is designed to distinguish
between real and fake sequences
so as the generator generates sequences
the critic will
evaluate those and it will guess which
ones are real and fake
but we know which ones are real and fake
so we can update the critic
and make it better at distinguishing
between real and fake sequences
and we can also update the generator
making it better at creating
convincingly fake sequences and then we
can
loop this over and over and over
allowing them
to compete in this way
and eventually you get to sequences that
you can't distinguish which ones are
real or fake
um but these uh
these neural networks sometimes collude
and they're also not perfect
here are two images that i took from
this person does not exist.com
the one on the right is clearly a face
the one on the left is clearly not a
face
but the neural network believed it was
so often the way to solve this problem
is to use some sort of generic
face detector that's not related to your
research and use it as
a check on what you see
now in the sequence world we would use
blast right it's been around since the
80s it is
incredibly effective at
finding sequences so using
a blast database created from
the validation data we can see
that the generated sequences through
time are able to create
sequences that convince even blast
that they are tat sequences
gans also allow us to do other
interesting things
for example if you have two
different points in space two different
random numbers a and b
you can determine
what their sequences are that correspond
with point a
and point b you can also use math
to linearly interpolate between the
vector a
and the vector b and then find the
sequences
that correspond to all of those
intermediate points between a and b
now what's interesting is the two
sequences that i
started with one of which was able to
bind to grin with the nmdma receptor
the other one was not now nicely
we have a neural network that is able to
predict
which hiv tap proteins are able to bind
to grain
and what we find is very interesting is
that
as we walk from a grin binding path to a
non-grim binding tat
we can see that it has a lower
prediction
of this binding potential
and this will allow us to look at
different proteins
in an experimental sense to see which of
these mutations
might be responsible for the change in
grin binding
so in conclusion i'd like to talk i'd
like to
sort of remind everybody that techniques
from varying sources
can be useful biological tools right i
showed how
sentiment analysis can be used for
functional protein prediction
showed how face identification could be
used for protein protein interaction
production
or how image generation can be used
to generate sequences that have
interesting properties
i also want to remind everybody of the
example
of tat that i've shared that biological
common sense is
critical when looking at these neural
networks
that they are not magic that they take
research and they take time to develop
and you have to really look and make
sure that the question you're trying to
answer
is one that is answerable with the data
that you have
so i'd like to thank my funding sources
uh this is my lab this was back in a
time where you could actually congregate
without masks
deborah here is my gene ontology wizard
and angie and bobby are
did the work on the early neural network
stuff
i also like to thank uh the participants
of the cares cohort that
uh that donated their sequences and all
the other researchers
of the 18th floor and the immid
and i want to close with one final slide
next up is josh earl we work together
uh on these types of projects and
i want to sort of give a lead in for his
as well
that these neural networks we have
trained to convert
sequence into protein function
now this means that this network has
learned the features that are important
for these protein functions
we can think of one of them as a feature
extractor and one of them is a predictor
and we can remove the predictor
and just look at the extracted features
and josh has talked we'll talk about how
those features can be useful in other
contexts
and he uses them to explore how
orthogonous genes may be related to each
other
thank you very much